it's 1992 and things were not looking
too good for the british economy the uk
was on the verge of a recession
inflation was out of control and for two
years the bank of england spent billions
trying to artificially prop up the value
of the british pound to avoid a complete
freefall but to no avail things were on
the verge of collapse everyone was
holding their breath waiting for
impending financial doom everyone except
for a man named george soros
it's the evening of september 15 1992
george soros turns to his associate and
tells him that it's quote time to go
nuclear end quotes
soros then bets everything he has
against the british pound
just 24 hours later his bet pays off the
value of the pound nose dives and george
soros walks away with over a billion
dollars in just 24 hours profiting from
the downfall of one of the world's
biggest economies it would be a day that
would go down in history the day george
soros broke the bank of england while at
the same time making more money than any
hedge fund manager has ever made in a
single day and from there his wealth and
power continued to skyrocket
today george soros is one of the
wealthiest people alive at a net worth
of 8.6 billion dollars but that number
is a little deceiving george soros is
actually worth a lot more than that
but george soros is smart he knows that
it's never too good to appear too rich
and powerful or else the peasants will
come knocking on your door with
pitchforks demanding you pay your fair
share that's why source actually has
around another 17 billion dollars stowed
away in what's called the open society
foundations which is basically a charity
that soros started that way on paper
soros is technically worth only around
89 billion dollars but he has control
over the rest of that money and he's
still able to use that money to shape
the world in his image while saving a
lot of money in taxes
this is because soros understands the
game he knows that it's not about how
much money you own because the money you
own can be taxed among other things but
it's all about how much money you
control see control is the name of the
game and soros has become a master at
control today's source is at the center
of many conspiracy theories he's thought
to be one of the key puppet masters of
the world the puppeteer behind things
that the european migrant crisis to
funding protests and riots in america to
provoking the 2018 armenian revolution
among other links but how much of it is
true
after all funding chaos is nothing new
the cia has been doing it for decades to
topple foreign leaders for just a few
million dollars each how far-fetched
could it be for a billionaire to do the
same
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player your parents teachers friends
society will never teach you any of this
so we're going to and this is george
soros
[Music]
the other day i was trying to find a
hotel but prices have been getting so
high and i was about to give up until i
tried this trick i learned i switched my
ip location to a different country using
my vpn and instantly i got a lower price
now not only is my vpn keeping me safe
online but i can even use it to save
money and that's why i'm so glad to have
surf shark surfshark is the best vpn for
the price out there it gives you
everything you need in a vpn and more
all in one easy to use app not for ten
dollars a month not for five dollars a
month but for just two dollars and 49
cents a month surfshark wants to make
sure everyone can afford to browse
safely and securely with surfsharks you
can access tv shows and movies on
streaming services that aren't available
in your country you can get past
geoblocks and government restrictions
you can constantly rotate your device's
ip address without losing your
connection to give you even more online
privacy and you can stay safe on public
wi-fi no matter where you go you can log
in on however many devices you want from
your laptop to your wi-fi router and
there's even a 30-day back guarantee so
you can try it out and decide if it's
the right fit for you so what are you
waiting for start protecting yourself
online today by going to
surfshark.dlktran with the link below
and when you use promo code j tran
you'll also get 83 off and an extra
three months free that's
surfshark.dlctran with the promo code
jake tran for 83 off in three months
free thanks to surfshark for sponsoring
this video
[Music]
why does anyone get into the world of
finance people who study medicine law or
politics might have some cliche
explanation like making the world a
better place or helping people but deep
down most doctors politicians and
lawyers who rise to the top of their
fields are in it for two things
the thrill and the money but the finance
guys they don't have time for pipe
dreams or even pretending to believe
them they're not planning on changing
the world they don't claim they're
trying to save lives they're there to
get the bag to get the money and the
glory that's it and in the world of
finance there's only one type of firm
that can give you both of those by the
bucket load a hedge fund hedge funds are
a special beast that allow the hedge
fund manager to get insanely rich in
very clever ways maybe we'll make a
video breaking this down in the future
but that was soros's first real move
into the world of high finance he
created his own hedge fund in 1970 and
by 1992 soros came across the
opportunity of a lifetime that would
change everything
[Music]
it was the end of world war ii european
countries had gone to war with each
other twice in the last 30 years and
something had to change the economic
cost and chaos were just too great to go
through again
but what could a bunch of random
european countries do to prevent another
war the answer raise the stakes for
everyone involved
make it so risky so economically stupid
to go to war that everyone in europe
would think twice or even three times
before taking the plunge
and the best way to do that was through
trade by trading with each other more
and making their economies dependent on
each other if one western european
country went down everyone else was
going down with it
that way the next european leader to
declare war would think long and hard
about the economic impact it would have
on his people before pulling the trigger
and it worked in 1951 a bunch of
european countries signed the treaty of
paris and created the european coal and
steel community
a couple of years later another treaty
led to the establishment of the european
economic community
basically over the next few decades
there were a lot of treaties a lot of
partnerships and a whole lot of
cooperation
but then around the 70s all these
european countries started thinking hey
if we're sharing our entire economy with
everyone else wouldn't it be easier to
just have one currency for all of us to
trade with
instead of wasting time money and effort
on converting german marks to french
francs and spanish liras why couldn't
they all just pick a single currency and
stick with it and that's where the erm
came in
in 1979 almost all the western european
countries joined what was called the
exchange rate mechanism or erm
the erm assigned every country a fixed
exchange rate pegged to the strongest
currency at the time the german mark
all that jargon basically means that
this new erm system would make trade
easier so that europe could slowly
transition to having just one currency
to rule them all everyone was happy to
get on board everyone except the uk
it took 11 years for britain to join the
erm and when they did it wasn't really
because they wanted to
things hadn't been going well for the uk
economy and they hoped that by finally
joining the erm their economy would
stabilize a bit but there were serious
problems
once the uk joined the erm the pound was
given a set value of 2.95 german marks
that means one british pound equaled
almost three german marks
they were given a six percent margin of
error on either side
meaning if the currency dropped or went
over that six percent they would be
kicked out
the only issue was before joining the
erm the uk had been on the verge of a
recession
inflation was out of control and joining
the erm had kind of just been a hail
mary to try to stop the economy from
spiraling
unfortunately not even that could help
october 1990
the uk officially joins the erm
and from his office in new york george
soros realizes he's been given the
opportunity of a lifetime
there's no way the uk can keep up with
all the restrictions and requests the
erm is throwing at them if soros could
buy his time if he could keep building
up his position against the british
pound before the currency drops he could
make unbelievable profits
so for the next two years he quietly
carefully builds up his short position
against the pound to 1.5 billion dollars
the uk government did everything it
could to stay in the erm
for two years the bank of england spent
billions of its foreign currency
reserves to buy pounds and keep the
value of the pound up
but by 1992
things weren't looking too good
there was no way the uk could keep up
its buying spree it was running out of
foreign currency and dropping out of the
erm was becoming inevitable
and here's the thing as soon as the uk
drops out of the erm all that money it
spent trying to artificially increase
the pound's value it would all be for
nothing
the pound's value would drop right down
to where it was supposed to be all along
and the uk economy it would lose
billions
it's quote time to go nuclear end quote
that's what george soros said to his
associate on september 15 1992 as the
british economy was on the verge of
collapse and here's how his short worked
let's say george soros had 15 of his
clients money in his hedge fund he would
take that 15 and exchange it for pounds
let's say he gets around 10 pounds he
would then go to british banks and say
hey i'm a famous hedge fund manager look
my accounts have 10 pounds in them could
i use that as collateral to get a loan
from you i'll pay you back with interest
and these companies would look at the
accounts and see soros's average returns
and think yeah why not
so they give him another 90 pounds
now what started out as 15
now turns into 100 pounds
he would then keep doing this exchange
dollars for pounds then go to british
banks to borrow more pounds and for the
next few months he'd hang on to his
pounds waiting for a sign that the pound
is about to crash
then right before it crashes he
exchanges his pounds for german marks
let's say 100 pounds would give him 295
marks
a day later the pound loses 10 percent
of its value
now if he exchanges the 295 marks back
he would get 110 pounds so he goes back
to the banks with his 110 pounds pays
them the 90 plus a little bit of
interest and walks away with almost 10
full pounds in profit
simple right
well imagine doing that on a scale of
billions of dollars
because that's what soros did
on the morning of september 15 1992
george soros had a 1.5 billion short
position against the pound that meant he
had around 1.5 billion dollars in pounds
waiting to exchange them for marx
that evening the president of germany's
central bank gave a statement saying
some countries would soon quote come
under pressure end quote from the erm
that was soros's sign
he told his associate to go for the
jugular
so as europe slept soros borrowed and
collected pounds from anyone he could as
quickly as the pounds flowed in he sold
them for marks by the time trading
opened on september 16 1992
george soros's short against a pound
equaled 10 billion dollars
as trading opened other hedge funds and
trading firms got wind of soros's bet
and started doing the exact same thing
selling pounds
as some hedge funds sold pounds more
hedge funds felt like they had to follow
suit
all of the selling meant bad news for
the pound and nothing the uk did could
keep it from losing value
they tried buying back pounds they tried
raising interest rates but the hedge
funds just kept selling every last pound
they had
by the end of september 16th the
inevitable had become a reality the uk
had to leave the erm
now with the pound back on the open
market all the bank of england's buying
to keep the currency stable came undone
the pound's value dropped nearly 15
percent and george soros he cashed in
his 10 billion dollars was worth well
over 11.5 billion now in just 24 hours
he had made more than a billion dollars
profiting from the downfall of one of
the world's biggest economies
[Music]
by 2016 george soros was worth nearly 25
billion dollars
he had made it in every sense of the
word he was rich he was successful he
was a legend in his industry
so in 2017 he donates more than 18
billion dollars of his own money to
charity such a nice charitable guy right
he's made all these billions over the
years and now he's looking to give back
think again
you see in 2008 a law was passed that
would put soros on the line for seven
billion dollars in tax by 2017 that's
more than 25 percent of everything he
had
so soros had to find an alternative
instead of paying seven billion dollars
in tax to a government that could use it
for whatever they wanted why not avoid
paying any tax at all
to do that he would follow the example
of hundreds of billionaires before him
he would donate to charity luckily for
him he already had the perfect charity
to donate to his own
for decades he had been the chairman of
the open society foundations a charity
that does everything from offering
scholarships to supporting independent
cultural groups and sure the money he
would donate to the charities wouldn't
technically be his anymore but he would
still have all the control
if he wanted to start a business in some
african country he could easily use his
charity to fund a local school or
hospital and in exchange
that country's government would have to
open all the doors necessary so in 2017
right before the tax laws that would
cost him seven billion dollars kicked in
he donated almost eighty percent of his
wealth to charity
coincidentally soros paid zero taxes
from 2016 to 2018.
his reason a couple of quote bad
investments end quote
just like he had always done soros had
played the system and walked away the
winner
over the years george soros has become
the subject of lots of different
conspiracy theories there was the one
where people claimed he had helped the
nazis to murder jews even though he was
only 13 years old at the time
several presidents including donald
trump have accused him of paying people
to protest against movements or laws he
doesn't like and of course he's been
accused of owning antifa and black lives
matter but we've looked into these
claims and the only thing we can really
accuse him of is being a smart and
sometimes very lucky businessman
george soros is a master at playing the
financial system to get what he wants
but he's not the only one who will go to
great lengths to achieve his goals the
american government is even more
notorious for the things it will do to
protect its interests and there's no
better example than the cia's black site
program
between 2001 and 2009 the cia kidnapped
hundreds of suspected arabic suspects to
interrogate using some of the most
brutal bloodthirsty techniques known to
man
it didn't matter that lots of those men
and women they were questioning were
actually innocent or that what they were
doing to them was completely illegal in
their minds every last despicable thing
they did to their prisoners was one
hundred percent justified
and honestly cia black sites and the
enhanced interrogation techniques they
used is probably the darkest most
sinister topic we've ever covered on
this channel
obviously going into the horrifying
details of the creative ways the cia
found to break their prisoners would set
off a million red flags and get any
public video instantly demonetized on
youtube
that's why to share every last
horrifying detail with you we've had to
release it as a full-length private
documentary available only to members of
this channel and all you have to do to
get access to this exclusive documentary
right now along with other full-length
videos on topics like the roots of
middle eastern terror efforty jepsteen
mk-ultra the cia's mind control program
is click that join button below people
pay tens of thousands of dollars to
attend university and leave still not
knowing anything about how the world
really works but by becoming a member
you'll get access to all this insider
info for only five dollars a month
and trust us it's way more entertaining
than university lectures
plus there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships
so if you join and you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining and we will personally
refund you for your first month
after your first month there is no
refund
so soros pretty controversial guy
couldn't really find much on him in
terms of like the conspiracy theories
are out there so that's whatever but
yeah if you're new here this is one of
the biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoyed this one click
that subscribe button below because we
make multiple videos just like this one
every single week for free you can
follow me on instagram jaytran and you
can also follow me on facebook jaytran
if you want shorter versions of these
videos but that's going to wrap it up
stay dangerous out there and i'll see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you